on va parler des marchés boursiers qui
ont dégringolé au cours des derniers
jours vous avez vu ça bien sûr les
craintes liées au corps en aveyron c'est
comme ça qu'on a expliqué la chute donc
à la bourse
et vous avez peut-être vu vos placements
fondre un petit peu ou beaucoup
ça dépend on va parler avec karine
surcote gestionnaire de portefeuille
chez et médicis matin bonjour madame sur
quinze jours j'imagine que vous avez
reçu des appels ces derniers jours de
clients et pied oui et non je peux pas
vous dire qu'on en a reçu moins ce
serait vous mentir mais je crois que le
fait qu'on travaille beaucoup au
préalable avec les clients et c'est ça
que les investisseurs doivent se
rappeler il doit avoir eu un plan de
match qui est établi au préalable
donc nous c'est notre travail je me dis
ou comme gestionnaire de portefeuille de
s'assurer de comprendre et de connaître
chacun nos clients dans l'optique où une
crise va survenir c'est ça qu'il faut
faire au préalable et non réagir
maintenant
mais quand on voit quand même les
marchés boursiers fondent comme ça
pendant la semaine on parle de 10 à 15%
est ce que les placements ont diminué
d'autant
est ce que c'est ça qu'on voit dans dans
les chiffres mais oui une correction
boursière c'est à dire une baisse de
plus de 10 pour ça c'est rare dans
l'histoire de la bourse américaine dans
les 40 dernières années c'est arrivé à
peu près une dizaine de fois seulement
en octobre 2008 lors de la grande crise
financière
alors oui la question on peut se poser
est ce que le corps n'avait russe un
impact réel sur la valeur des
entreprises cotées en bourse
et je crois que le meilleur exemple
c'est à paul il a dû annoncer apport
c'est quand même une entreprise
gigantesque un point 2 trillions de
capitalisation boursière
donc ça représente entre 4 et 5% de la
valeur du standard and poor's 500
d'enfants de l' indice et elle a annoncé
à ses investisseurs qu'elle devait
réviser à la baisse ses cibles de vente
parce que oui elle va vendre moins de
iphone en chine sa chaîne
d'approvisionnement est intégrée
mondialement dont il ya un impact réel
mais est-ce qu'on se doit se poser la
question lorsqu'on investit en bourse
est ce qu'il ya un impact sur cinq ans
est ce que nous comme investisseur ça
nous empêche de prévoir sur une plus une
période plus long terme signés
et à long terme exactement regarder
s'avoue essayé de rassurer aussi vos
clients quand même c
le coronavirus ça prend de l'expansion
pays en pays on ne voit pas
nécessairement la fin tout de suite non
plus alors est ce qu'on peut imaginer
qu'on puisse tomber en récession puis
que qui a des impacts beaucoup plus
important dans le fond ce les certitudes
c'est sûr qu'elle est là et je peux
peut-être rappeler étant donné qu'il est
en entrevue récemment monsieur wang au
fait que la capacité de rappeler des
principes importants et lui il gère un
conglomérat de plusieurs entreprises
dont plusieurs millions sont investis
dans à pau il ramène la vision à long
terme et il dit c'est pas la première
fois ni la dernière fois qu'un événement
extraordinaire c'est sûr qu'on connaît
pas l'ampleur encore vont affecter la
trajectoire des entreprises mais
lorsqu'on investit en bourse et
lorsqu'on a des objectifs que ce soit
pour la retraite prendre une année
sabbatique
on doit se poser ces questions là avant
et c'est ce qu'on fait avec les clients
et la tolérance au risque quand vous
dites on voit fondre les placements on
essaie de vous mettre en situation
au préalable est ce que si vous vivez
une baisse de 20 mille cinquante mille
cent mille de votre portefeuille comment
allez-vous réagir oui c'est ça avez-vous
déjà vécu d'un niveau de risque une
telle est oubliée avant toute chose lui
on est proche de la retraite
à ce moment ci est ce qu'on garde
l'argent là qu'est ce que vous
recommander à vos clients
mais c'est pas le bon moment
effectivement faut faire un changement
de stratégie si on est près de la
retraite
j'ose espérer que cela était prévu avant
normalement les décaissements qu'on
prévoit refaire dans les cinq prochaines
années ils ne seront pas investis en
bourse
on appelle la répartition d'actifs entre
les actions par exemple notre classe
d'actifs qui sont les revenus fixes qui
vont moins réagir à ce qui se passe
actuellement
on doit prévoir ça donc nous c'est les
les risques un client nous appelle dans
un moment comme ça pour décaisser est ce
qu'il avait prévu cette situation donc
c'est parler de revoir votre situation
et de voir si c'est vraiment un élément
important qui ait changé
si on est à une autre phase de sa vie
mais qu'on est plutôt au début de l'âge
adulte ou qu'on est
années qu'on veut investir ça peut être
un bon moment par contre tout à fait
dans le trailer les actions sont intérêt
luis et squillaci ce qui arrive ce que
l'évaluation comme nous l'autre facette
pour rassurer les clients c'est la
composition du portefeuille
oui d'avoir des entreprises de qualité
mais également de payer un prix
raisonnable pour acquérir les
entreprises donc ça devient un bon
moment où ce qui épargne de façon
systématique vont profiter de ces
moments là donc c'est de demeurer
investi selon le plan initial qui avait
été établi et pour les jeunes c'est
c'est une bonne occasion pour entrer en
bourse et vous savez certainement
l'actualité de très près aux états unis
bon premier mort lié au corona virus a
en fin de semaine l'association qui
prend quand même de l'ampleur et à quoi
vous attendez quand la bourse va rouvrir
demain matin on ne fait pas de
prévisions donc c'est impossible à
prévoir ce qu'on a appris c'est 2 comme
je vous disais d'avoir une qualité
d'entreprises en portefeuille ça nous
rassure donc peu d'être rentable avec
des liquidités aussi au bilan et ça ça
nous aide à passer au travers des crises
mais qu'est-ce que lundi va nous offrir
on ne sait jamais sauf qu'on est prêts
on suit plusieurs entreprises donc celle
de vienne à un bon prix sabre est une
bonne occasion dans une bonne
préparation ça permet de restaurer nos
clients aussi c'est très important de
les rassurer et de ramener qui ont des
objectifs parce que le côté force de la
bourse et sa propre us des rendements
aussi pour atteindre des objectifs
financiers à long terme
merci 2020 merci quincy au roi